est-ce qu'il y a quelqu'un ici qui a
déjà vécu un truc comme ça très
traumatisant une honte un mauvais papier
ou non vraiment pour te répondre je ne
l'ai jamais vécu parce que j'ai toujours
été très très parano avec ça et que
justement je fais toujours en sorte de
ne pas envoyer de photos de ne pas faire
de vidéo ça arrive qu'on me demande et
que je dise maintenant je ne veux pas en
faire non mais c'est pas arrivé une
photo un truc qui traîne et bien sûr
pour moi le truc qui blesse c'est le
truc que tu dis ma mère va le voir et
les enfants nous les enfants non mais
par contre il y a des gens des médias
qui m'envoient leurs Dick pic c'est à
dire quoi leur photo de partie intime il
y a des stars qui t'envoient leurs idées
des animateurs des gens dans la
politique je reçois et je leur dis mais
heureusement que je suis cortiquée parce
que je pourrais balancer la photo alors
moi je pense aussi je pense que ça
pourrait m'abîmer moi aussi dans ma
carrière le fait de les de d'Yves en
fait attention pas du tout Agatha c'est
pas le sujet non mais c'est vrai genre
non il parle un peu j'aime bien ce que
tu fais tu es drôle dans tes PMP people
tu es drôle si c'est machin voici ma
teub est-ce que tu passerais pas à
[Applaudissements]
la main dans la politique
[Musique]
Paris moi j'ai deux trois mille
euros quoi
sur snap comme ça la photo il disparaît
après c'est malin
tous les deux vous recevez des sexes de
personnes connues
non c'est pas vrai non mais oui c'est
quand même très surpris et surpris aussi
d'un truc c'est que vous êtes petit
chroniqueur je suis énorme star je ne
reçois aucune photo de top de la Mairie
de Paris en sortant
c'est parti pour les tu vois donc voilà
c'est un petit truc qui est drôle c'est
voilà je vais mettre votre pardon je
vous ai demandé votre pire honte
certains du l'oublier puisque notamment
une pour Deborah elle avait fait un clip
de bord avec feu à gâteau pro qu'on aime
beaucoup qui aime une émission ici et je
sais pas pourquoi parce que aujourd'hui
tu veux être connu
c'est pour
une vue chanter avec Agathe écoute moi
j'adore la musique alors j'adore chanter
Laurent le sait hein
j'adore
du coup j'étais dans une cabine on m'a
dit bah tiens je chante ça et c'est je
pense que déjà il faut arrêter le coup
des Asos capucine anav je l'aime du fond
du cœur donc je dis la vérité quelle
émission la paix sur TF1 première
compagnie
et on lui dit elle arrive chez un bémol
on lui dit c'est quoi ton sauce hein
je sais pas bon tu auras la sauce nez
rouge d'accord c'est quoi c'est une Asos
avec des clowns et ils vont amuser des
enfants qui sont malades dans les
hôpitaux ok allez on fait la première et
toi capucine bien sûr moi je suis très
très attaché aux enfants quand on est
rouge pour moi l'association le nez des
enfants non c'est pas ça mais c'est pas
ça on va la refaire c'est rouge
dix fois pour qu'elle capte la sauce
alors les assassin c'est très touchant
mais toujours c'est vrai
bah voilà alors en attendant même si la
cause était bonne je pense que ça n'a
pas servi la cause regarde
on remettrai oui je t'aimais c'était
avant tu ne me regarde même plus je suis
devenue une inconnue pourquoi
[Musique]
pourquoi
es-tu comme ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est vraiment à chaque fois
plus d'un n'importe quoi sinon les
enfants font plus entre Bien et le Mal
regarde ma gueule de Jean-Michel en haut
à droite à plus tard c'est pas moi c'est
un sosie
est-ce que vous savez quand même elle
est vachement après un degré mais est-ce
que vous savez que Deborah chante
beaucoup et souvent comme ça
N'oubliez pas les paroles c'est mon rêve
ça ou peut-être The Voice j'avais passé
des sélections de N'oubliez pas les
paroles j'avais été jusqu'à la dernière
étape jusqu'à ce qu'il se rende compte
que je travaille pour bannierger bon là
du coup c'était mort d'accord et là ce
qu'on va faire c'est que du coup bah
c'est pas grave comme les gens aiment
maintenant
si l'automne chasse en été de plus la 4L
est morte on a repeint la rue
[Musique]
dedans petit Jean et grand et forts
[Applaudissements]